Trascrizione: Michele Gianella
Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
A voi interessa l'impressione
che fate alle persone,
la prima volta che le incontrate?
A me sì, e cerco sempre
di mantenere un profilo basso.
Ho sempre pensato che mantenere
un profilo basso, nella vita, paga.
Paga perché arrivi alle persone
per quello che sei.
Non serve ostentare.
Aldilà del fatto che sono così,
e che è parte del mio carattere.
Ma poi, un giorno ti invitano
su un palco di un TED.
E tu pensi: ma adesso, ora,
di cosa parlo a un TED?
Io che non amo mettere
me stesso al centro,
soprattutto per parlare di cose personali.
E quindi ho pensato:
perché non parlare di come cerco
di mettere sempre gli altri al centro,
soprattutto in un contesto lavorativo?
E di quanto mi piace farlo?
Ma prima di salire su questo palco,
ho fatto dell'altro nella vita.
Dopo l'università, il primo bivio.
Ho avuto l'opportunità di fare
due colloqui per due percorsi diversi:
un posto fisso in banca,
e un contratto a tempo determinato
in una grande azienda,
per un progetto che sarebbe dovuto
poi chiudersi dopo qualche mese.
Io ho il papà, ed entrambi i nonni,
che hanno lavorato in banca,
quindi la carriera poteva essere
segnata dall'inizio.
E soprattutto, 20 anni fa
le parole "posto fisso" e "banca"
non sarebbero state soltanto
la gioia dei nonni,
ma probabilmente avrebbero anche generato
un applauso spontaneo in sala.
Ma io avevo le idee chiare.
E così, avendo passato
entrambi i colloqui,
sentivo che il mio desiderio, la mia sfida
era entrare in una grande azienda.
Perché nella mia immaginazione
di studente universitario,
ho sempre pensato
che una grande azienda avrebbe voluto dire
un contesto dinamico,
un percorso da costruire strada facendo.
Così sono entrato in azienda;
ho preso parte al mio progetto;
sono stato poi assunto;
ho fatto diverse esperienze,
tutte interessanti;
e ho cercato sempre di mettermi in mostra
per l'atteggiamento giusto,
non soltanto le competenze tecniche.
Dopo qualche anno,
avevo raggiunto un buon ruolo
ed avevo creato un rapporto molto forte
con uno dei miei team di allora.
Solo che ero ancora abbastanza giovane,
e quindi ho iniziato a pensare:
ma tra qualche anno?
Sarà ancora così, la mia motivazione?
E allora, sorprendendo
un po' anche me stesso,
ho risposto ad una chiamata
per cambiare lavoro
e mi sono trasferito a Roma, prima da solo
e poi raggiunto dalla famiglia.
E Roma e la moda,
perché sono entrato nella moda,
mi hanno fatto scoprire un mondo:
networking, esperienze professionali
veramente importanti;
una città meravigliosa,
con luoghi magici tutti da scoprire.
Ma io di indole non devo sedermi;
voglio sempre fare qualcosa.
E così, quando gli stimoli
stavano per mancare
mi sono buttato a testa bassa
nell'ultimo cambiamento,
tra l'altro avvenuto durante la pandemia.
Mi sono spostato in Veneto,
e sono entrato nella bellissima
realtà in cui sono oggi,
dove gli stimoli non mancano di certo
e ho l'opportunità di guidare
team numerosi e multiculturali
in giro per il mondo.
Ma io non sono mai stato un carrierista.
Non è mai stato quello il mio obiettivo.
La carriera è sempre stata la conseguenza
di come mi sono sempre messo in gioco.
E ogni tanto ci ripenso,
a come potrebbe essere la mia vita ora
se avessi fatto una scelta diversa
in uno di quei momenti.
Magari non sarei qui sul palco
con voi oggi - o forse sì, chissà.
Ma c'è un momento in particolare,
durante il mio percorso,
che segna una svolta per me.
Durante un corso di leadership,
ho la fortuna di incontrare un coach
che ha contribuito parecchio
alla mia crescita personale
e professionale.
Tra le varie cose, ricordo uno strumento
che mi ha insegnato ad utilizzare
e che per me è stato molto importante,
perché oltre a darmi
una serie di conferme,
mi aveva permesso di mettere
un po' a fuoco
il percorso che potevo avere davanti.
Si chiama la "matrice dell'identità"
e più che rispondere a delle domande,
mi ha aiutato a pormi quelle giuste.
Io lo trovo un esercizio bellissimo,
nella sua semplicità;
e ve lo vorrei condividere
perché così come ha aiutato me,
potrebbe fare altrettanto
con alcuni di voi.
Si tratta di combinare su due assi
quello che vorresti essere,
o non vorresti essere,
e non sarai mai, potresti diventare
o sarai sempre.
Ad esempio, cosa non vorreste essere
ma potreste diventare?
Nel mio caso, demotivato.
Ma questa consapevolezza mi ha aiutato
a cercare sempre di mantenere
accesa la mia fiammella.
E potreste veramente pensare
a diverse combinazioni,
ed interrogarvi su voi stessi;
ma ora ve la tolgo,
perché altrimenti so come funziona;
non mi ascoltate più,
e ciao TEDx di Matteo.
Ma guardate, è bello
interrogarsi su queste cose;
e se fate queste riflessioni
in maniera profonda, vostra,
capirete che alcune
delle risposte che darete
poi non cambiano nel corso della vita,
perché è difficile modificare
la tua personalità, la tua identità.
Si può lavorare sulla parte centrale,
su quello che potresti essere
e far si che accada, o non accada,
a seconda che tu lo voglia
o non lo voglia.
Ma badate bene, questo è solo uno
dei tanti strumenti che si vedono in giro,
ma non stiamo parlando del Santo Graal;
non è lo strumento
su cui oggi bisogna concentrarsi,
ma sulle vostre risposte.
E io, in particolar modo,
vorrei commentarvi due delle mie.
Quello che voglio essere
e non sarò mai? Un artista.
e sarò sempre? Un altruista.
Artista e Altruista,
due concetti che si incontrano
e che rappresentano un po'
l'essenza del mio essere.
Ma andiamo con ordine.
Ci sono stati tanti momenti nella vita,
e ogni tanto capita ancora,
in cui avrei tanto voluto
essere un'artista.
Uno di quelli che si esprimono
con le opere d'arte,
i quadri in particolare.
Non che non ci abbia mai provato.
Uno dei primi regali
che mi ha fatto mia moglie
è stato un cavalletto
professionale per dipingere.
All'epoca sentivo davvero
di avere un talento inespresso,
da dipingere su una tela.
Ma era talmente inespresso
che quella tela non è mai
uscita dall'armadio. Mai.
Ma non sto scherzando,
mi sarebbe davvero piaciuto dipingere.
Ma poi altri interessi, altre priorità -
o probabilmente le scuse,
hanno preso il sopravvento.
Capita, no?
"Non sarò mai un artista"
è un'affermazione abbastanza netta:
E non sono solito farle così nette,
soprattutto quando è
qualcosa a cui ambisco.
Le affermazioni, in generale,
chiudono la mente;
io preferisco farmi una domanda,
richiamare un'azione:
"Come potrei diventare un artista?"
"In che modo potrei esprimere un talento?"
Qualche giorno fa,
mia figlia di quasi otto anni,
mentre provavo questa parte,
mi ha sentito,
e probabilmente ha sentito
anche la parte precedente.
È entrata e mi ha detto:
"Papà, tira fuori la tela
e dipingi: semplice, no?".
I bambini, nella loro innocenza,
vedono sempre soluzioni facili:
ma sarebbe facile davvero,
solo che a me non è mai venuto.
Non ci sono mai riuscito.
Non sempre facciamo le cose che vogliamo.
E così, quando questa cosa
ha iniziato a dispiacermi,
in assenza di un talento specifico,
ho iniziato ad interrogarmi
sul concetto di talento
che, così come artista,
è una parola bellissima
che racchiude più di un significato.
Spetta a noi scoprire
quello che più ci appartiene.
E allora ho spostato l'attenzione
dal saper fare - talento pratico -
al saper essere, che è
un altro tipo di virtù.
E questa cosa penso
che mi contraddistingue.
Ma io non è che faccio le cose
meglio degli altri, ci mancherebbe,
ma sicuramente ci metto passione,
ci metto energia, ci metto entusiasmo.
Le nostre emozioni impattano
su quello che facciamo,
e lo rendono unico.
Qualche tempo fa,
mi sono trovato a parlare
a dei ragazzi molto più giovani,
e ho cercato di trasferire
questi concetti.
Solo che in quell'occasione,
sono stato un po' frainteso.
O meglio, non sono riuscito
ad esprimermi in maniera efficace.
Perché ogni tanto capita.
E un ragazzo è intervenuto, e mi ha detto:
"Ma scusa, i miei genitori
si fanno un mazzo così per farmi studiare
e arrivi tu a parlare
e valorizzare il saper essere?".
Ma no, dai, non estremizziamo
questo concetto.
È importante saper fare le cose,
farle bene
ed essere padrone di quello che dici.
È importante valorizzare
il percorso di studi di una persona.
Il saper essere consolida
delle competenze.
Non è che basta impegnarsi,
per fare bene qualcosa.
Però è vero il contrario:
tu potrai anche fare bene qualcosa,
ma se non ci metti del tuo,
se non ci metti quel valore aggiunto,
mancherà sempre qualcosa.
In parte collegato a questo concetto,
c'è la seconda risposta
che voglio raccontarvi.
Il fatto che io sarò sempre un altruista.
Mi piace dare alle altre persone.
E unendo poi i puntini,
ho imparato poi a riconoscermi
nella definizione di "giver"
di Adam Grant.
Che oggi non vi spiego:
ma se qualcuno non la conosce,
c'è un suo TED molto bello sull'argomento
che vi invito a guardare.
L'essere un giver non è stato
solo un punto di forza, per me:
ma man mano che crescevo di ruolo,
è diventato un po' il mio perché,
il mio obiettivo professionale.
Cercare di diventare un mentore,
un artista che prova
a far splendere le persone.
E così, ogni tanto,
mi ci metto di impegno:
lo faccio in maniera
anche abbastanza artigianale,
molto genuina se volete.
E organizzo diverse cose
per le persone che lavorano con me.
Recentemente, ad esempio,
ho lanciato un appuntamento periodico
in cui chiamo persone del mio network
a confrontarsi su temi diversi.
E facciamo una chiacchierata
davanti a tutto il mio team;
invito tutti, qualsiasi età
e qualsiasi ruolo.
Ovviamente non sono obbligati,
ma sono tutti invitati.
È una chiacchierata virtuale
molto spontanea;
ma cerco comunque
di guidare la conversazione
su argomenti che possano offrire
uno spunto, uno stimolo per loro.
Alcuni non capiscono subito
che sotto c'è anche un messaggio
da portarsi a casa;
e pensano che sia, più che altro,
un momento che serve per decomprimere
certe giornate lavorative.
Ed è così, è anche quello.
Ma ricordate Karate Kid?
Dai la cera, togli la cera?
Io sono convinto che quando serve,
poi, vengono fuori.
E sapete perché è importante questa cosa,
e sta venendo benissimo?
Perché è fatta per loro, e loro lo sanno.
Ogni tanto, quando lo racconto in giro,
alcuni mi dicono "Wow, che figata!
Perché non lo metti
su una piattaforma pubblica,
così partecipiamo anche noi
e ti ascoltiamo?"
No!
È l'intimità del mio team,
che è la chiave del successo.
Se lo aprissi,
non sarebbe più per loro,
ma per me, per il mio personal branding.
Perderebbe lo scopo, e fine della magia.
Io sono sempre più convinto
che ad un certo punto della carriera
uno debba occuparsi un po' di meno
di far funzionare le cose,
e cercare sempre di più
di spostare l'attenzione sulle persone,
perché poi sono loro
che fanno funzionare le cose.
E se "fai funzionare" le persone,
inteso come: gli fai da mentore;
cerchi di farle esprimere;
gli traferisci delle competenze;
li fai lavorare con entusiasmo
e tieni la motivazione alta,
poi le cose accadono.
E accadono anche meglio.
A me questa cosa non me l'ha
dovuta spiegare nessuno.
Mi viene sempre molto naturale.
Il fatto che le persone sono importanti
è una cosa che ho sempre pensato.
Le persone fanno la differenza:
lo vediamo scritto dappertutto.
Si, ma poi bisogna anche essere coerenti.
Bisogna cercare di metterle
nelle condizioni di fare la differenza.
O no?
Sì.
(Applausi)
Qualche anno fa ho utilizzato
anche la matrice dell'identità
con alcune delle persone del mio team.
Solo che io non sono un coach,
non sono un formatore.
Per me sarebbe stato veramente difficile
interpretare le loro risposte,
ed aiutarle in modo concreto.
Però volevo metterci del mio.
Volevo andare un po' oltre
quello che il coach aveva fatto con me.
E allora mi sarebbe piaciuto
farla diventare un oggetto
per personalizzare le loro scrivanie,
e magari creare qualche
occasione di confronto,
così, per farli interagire tra loro,
magari approfondendo
alcune delle loro risposte.
Solo che non mi sembrava
un gadget abbastanza colorato
da mettere su una scrivania.
Allora ho pensato:
"perché non cercare delle immagini
da associare alle loro personalità?".
Bello, ma tosto.
Mi stavo un po' incartando:
ma poi sono capitato
sulla pagina Instagram
di una illustratrice,
una ragazza che disegna frasi
di canzoni o citazioni di film.
Wow, perfetto, quello che fa per me.
Perché lei interpreta e disegna.
La contattai, e mi fece 40 disegni.
E c'era anche il mio,
che oggi voglio mostrarvi;
perché seppur non conoscendomi,
come io non conosco voi,
mi aveva offerto
un consiglio molto prezioso,
quasi un booster di autostima.
"Non devi mai pensare di non meritare
ciò che vuoi, capito?"
È una frase presa dal film:
"10 cose che odio di te".
Una carezza e una sberla
allo stesso tempo.
Sono questi esercizi, queste riflessioni
che ci devono aiutare
a farci mettere in gioco.
Quando guardo questo disegno,
e lo guardo spesso,
penso a quanto sia importante
cercare di prendere il controllo
sulle nostre vite.
Ma io lo so, eh,
che parlare delle nostre emozioni
ci mette a disagio.
Non pensate che sia facile per me, oggi,
stare qui a raccontarvi queste cose.
Ma paradossalmente, il sentirsi a disagio
può anche essere un bene.
E per spiegarvi meglio quello che intendo,
vorrei utilizzare una metafora
che racconto spesso alle persone
che lavorano con me.
Solo che non l'ho inventata io,
non mi prendo i meriti.
Voi sapete come crescono le aragoste?
Le aragoste hanno un corpo molle,
e un guscio rigido.
Quando crescono, si sentono
sotto pressione.
Quindi vanno sotto una roccia,
per proteggersi dai predatori,
rompono il guscio
e ne producono uno più grande.
E così fanno man mano che crescono.
Il messaggio sottostante
è che lo stimolo per crescere
è quello di sentirsi
un po' a disagio e sotto pressione,
che è una condizione
che ci forza a cambiare.
Senza quello stimolo,
rischieremmo di mettere
il pilota automatico
e di essere assuefatti
dalla nostra routine.
Sarebbe molto più difficile,
arrivare ad un livello successivo.
E allora? Cosa possiamo fare?
Beh, io dico:
"Bruciare sempre, spegnersi mai!"
Che è una frase di una canzone
diventata il mio motto.
Il motto delle persone
che vogliono vivere con entusiasmo.
Circondiamoci di persone
che siano per noi fonte di ispirazione,
uno stimolo.
Ma soprattutto, tiriamo fuori
le nostre tele dall'armadio,
e dipingiamo le nostre vite.
Perché è mentre dipingi,
che viene fuori il quadro.
(Applausi)